geht das nicht doch ohne putins gas ohne
putins öl auszukommen vor dieser frage
stehen wir anhand dieser bilder aufs
neue und vitali klitschko sagt ganz ganz
ganz prägnant ganz konkret keinen
einzigen cent mehr für putin lösen sie
das ein kein cent mehr wir müssen putin
möglichst schnell treffen aber auch
wirksam treffen also noch ist vieles
händen wissen wir in zehn milliarden wir
werden nicht von heute auf morgen aus
der gasversorgung aus russland eins zu
eins aufsteigen können das wird nicht
funktionieren ohne dass wir erhebliche
schäden bei uns auch tatsächlich haben
und dann werden wir nicht mehr in der
lage der ukraine auch zu helfen in
irgend einer art und weise wenn bei uns
die komplette wirtschaft am boden ich
das wirklich sehr anders gelegen ist das
alles entscheidende jetzt alles zu tun
um so schnell wie möglich vom jahren
begonnen das wissen wir daran die worte
von vier oder fünf wochenenden sie
anders sprechen wenn chemie waffen zum
einsatz gekommen wären wäre dann eine
rote linie überschritten wo man dann
doch den gashahn abdrehte oder was ist
was ist diese rote linie oder gibt es
gar keine rote linie und putin kann
machen was er will wir zahlen weiter für
russisches gas ich glaube wir sollten
uns hier nicht über einzelne
angriffsarten unterhalten der gesamte
krieg ist ein gräuel ist ein grausamer
als ereignis vom ersten toten an ist das
schon ein toter zu viel gewesen und
deswegen muss dieser krieg so schnell
wie möglich beendet werden
da ist viel diplomatie gefordert da
müssen wir auch eine menge über hatten
auch nicht über einzelne ins boot nehmen
um dann auch jetzt schon so wirksam
werden zu lassen doch ich möchte die
über die konditionen sprechen weil es
mittlerweile nach diesen mehr als fünf
wochen eine andere dimension noch mal
bekommen hat dieser krieg und weil man
sich schon fragt wann es eigentlich bei
ihnen bei der ampel regierung dieser
punkt erreicht um aufs russische gas zu
verzichten weil im moment ist dieser
punkt ja für sie noch nicht erreicht wir
treffen putin viel härter wenn es uns
gelingt in den nächsten monaten einen
weg zur findung dauerhaft aus dem bezug
von energie aus russland aussteigen zu
können das muss das ziel sein drei
monate jetzt nichts zu importieren aus
russland hilft im ergebnis nicht viel
weiter deswegen müssen wir jetzt schnell
von ana zu einer dauerhaften lösung
kommen eine wirtschaftsbeziehung mehr
mit russland versehen müssen das ist das
entscheidende das trifft putin auf dauer
viel härter und ist auch eine größere
bedrohung für ihn frau wer das macht
doch was auch wie sie als politikerin
wie sie herr kutcher hat die sie haben
mag was sie herr herrmann als politiker
in den spiegel gucken müssen wir wissen
doch alle dass das keine unerheblichen
zahlungen sind die an russland weiter
fließen jetzt können wir im moment uns
schönreden dass das nicht sofort
umgemünzt werden kann in panzer und den
raketen und doch zahlen wir für dieses
russische gas und russische öl jeden tag
weiter vitali klitschko sagt wie gesagt
ab sofort kein cent mehr man kann zu
keinem anderen schluss kommen wenn man
auf diese bilder von buseck räumt können
sie noch guten gewissens frau b diese
zahlungen mittragen können sie noch
erklären warum wir millionen milliarden
cents weiterhin nach moskau überweisen
ich habe das für mich persönlich ja
schon geäußert dass ich finde dass wir
genau diese zahlungen einstellen müssen
dass jetzt auch die nächsten schritte
der sanktionen gegeben müssen gehend
gegangen werden müssen also jetzt eben
auch bei den fragen energie ölimporte
stoppen kohl wir haben ja schritte
ergriffen innerhalb der europäischen
union
einkaufsgemeinschaften zu bilden andere
lieferanten zu finden ölproduktion in
anderen staaten eben zu erhöhen und ja
es wird uns hart treffen aber ich habe
den eindruck aus gesprächen die ich mit
der bevölkerung führe dass hier die
menschen wesentlich weiter sind in
unserer gesellschaft dass sie sagen wir
wollen diesen kriegsverbrecher putin
kein geld mehr überweisen und ich hoffe
dass die äußerungen von dem
ratspräsidenten schein michelle jetzt so
zu verstehen ist dass dies in kürzester
zeit zwischen den mitgliedstaaten
abgestimmt wird wie gesagt das
europäische parlament das sich auch als
vizepräsidentin vertreten ist hier schon
längst weiter und fordert dies schon
seit längerem hermann noch einmal ganz
kurz und klar gehen sie damit also
stoppt sofort auch wenn es uns gewaltige
kosten verursacht und erhebliche
probleme schafft das ist ja völlig klar
aus meiner sicht muss eindeutig die
unmittelbare unterstützung für die
ukraine im vordergrund stehen weil er
die soldaten russland stehen
ukrainischen boden ich will diese
wirtschaftsnationen überhaupt nicht
infrage stellen aber ich habe große
zweifel dass sich putin darf man
jedenfalls kurzfristig beeindrucken
lässt und das entscheidende ist dass wir
die ukraine massiv unterstützen mit
waffen mit panzern mit munition und zwar
sofort und zwar nicht darüber
diskutieren was die in vier wochen
kriegen die brauchen das jetzt es ist
ein mutiges voll ich bin wirklich
beeindruckt davon wie die überhaupt
diesen widerstand organisieren wie die
ukrainische armee unterwegs ist und die
braucht jetzt sofort ihr die
unterstützung damit sie jetzt sich
weiter wehren kann es ist das meine ist
das entscheidende um die russische armee
zu stoppen der markt hat noch einmal zum
abschluss dieser runde die frage wir
haben nochmal diese fischer rede in den
ohren müsste eine ähnliche bernburg oder
eine ähnliche rede jetzt folgen und ja
unter dem einsatz der ganzen politischen
leidenschaft erklärt werden warum wir
eben auf putins gas verzichten warum die
grünen ein grüner wirtschaftsminister
eine grüne außenministerin jetzt auf
putins gas verzichten kostet das ja was
es wolle also ich habe nicht das gefühl
dass sich die ampel regierung das gerade
besonders leicht macht aber es gibt zum
beispiel experten die sagen wenn wir
jetzt sofort den gashahn abdrehen dann
sind die folgen bei uns relativ hart und
es kann sein dass durch die steigende
nachfrage aus europa die dann mit einmal
auf dem weltmarkt auftritt die gaspreise
so explodieren dass putin am ende mehr
geld hat als feuer und das kann ja auch
nicht das ziel sein ich bin aber total
dabei dass wir sagen wir müssen jetzt so
schnell wie möglich aus diesem gas
aussteigen und wir müssen dann eben auch
die wirtschaftlichen konsequenzen tragen
dafür muss der staat dann eben die
verantwortung auch übernehmen da muss
man dann geld bereitstellen dann ist
eben die schuldenbremse dieses jahr
nicht einzuhalten und im nächsten jahr
vielleicht auch nicht aber wir können
der ukraine nicht erklären dass wir
aufgrund wirtschaftlicher faktoren bei
uns weil wir nicht bereit sind den preis
zu zahlen für das machen viren können
und dass wir aufgrund dieser positiven
folgen jetzt da einfach zuschauern in
der ukraine und deswegen glaube ich auch
dass wir in diesem bereich deutlich
schneller deutlich weiter gehen sollten
und dass wir auch im europäischen
kontext schauen sollten mit den 27 eu
staaten wie können wir denn dann die
folgen möglichst gering gestalten und
wie können wir auch wenn es zum beispiel
der industrie dann zu einbrüchen kann
das dann mit geld ausgleichen dazu muss
aber in der ampel regierung dann auch
ein konsens da sein dass man die
wirtschaft nicht alleine lässt letzte
frage an den spd spitzenmann kutschaty
was ist diese rote linie das würde ich
gerne verstehen was ist die rote linie
für putins gas und was ist die rote
linie möglicherweise auch ein blick auf
sogar ein militärisches eingreifen
ich halte ein militärisches eingreifen
der nato für nicht angezeigt glaube
keiner möchte deutschland möchte die
nato in einen dritten weltkrieg stoßen
und stürzen und das wäre der fall so das
wäre tatsächlich der voll mit
verheerenden folgen auf dem ganzen
kontinent das muss mit allen mitteln
verhindert werden und deswegen geht es
jetzt darum putin in die knie zu zwingen
mit den instrumenten die wir als
friedliche westliche welt haben das sind
die harten sanktionen das sind
diplomatische maßnahmen und dazu müssen
wir jetzt aber die gesamte
weltgemeinschaft ich war nach der roten
jahren auch mitzumachen ich halte auch
nichts davon jetzt über rote linien
hierzu diskutieren und wladimir putin
jetzt sämtliche strategien offenzulegen
die wir jetzt hier auch tatsächlich
haben das ist zwar immer gerne und sehr
schön gesagt unser populär auch aber
taktisch bringt das uns keinen
zentimeter weiter wenn wir hier über
rote linien sprechen das würde ihnen mal
ein hegen man hat einfach den eindruck
er kann tun und lassen was er will und
deswegen finden ja diese krise
verbrechen konnten in butter auch stadt
wir ziehen kurzen strich darunter